draft rooms that we most like
or would like to be in as the case may
be on draft day 2021 that is today's
topic chris you have a trivia question
for me to determine pick number one
running backs in the first round mike
running backs in the first round can you
name the last three first round running
backs drafted by your team the minnesota
vikings first round round you can do
this is not crazy it's all within the
last 30 years
yeah no i think i got it uh it's adrian
peterson he's the most recent right
right right uh robert smith before that
yep
and then chuck foreman nope sorry
damn it
uh last 30 years remember i told you you
didn't listen to me that's usual yes
michael michael bennett michael bennett
2001 michael bennett deuce mcallister
was sliding down the board that's who
the vikings wanted the saints took him
and then the vikings took wisconsin
speedster michael bennett who ran like a
four oh yeah one or something like that
no you're right you're not a foot injury
man you're not a superhero man you just
know that every draft of that team right
just well i got the trivia question
wrong
i got i clearly got it wrong i'd
forgotten all about michael bennett uh
because he got a foot injury and uh that
was that okay you got the first pick
draft room you'd most like to be in this
year well okay i mean there's some good
options here there definitely is one i
tend to area on the ones that you know
got a lot of picks i think that's where
i'm gonna go to here first and i think
the first one i'm gonna go to that at
least is really interesting to me
is the dolphins the dolphins sitting at
sitting at number six of course have the
pick at 18 have another pick towards the
top of the second round so there's gonna
be a lot of action there for them to
make moves do things like that i'd love
to hear the dialogue at six if it's like
you know
depending on what what receivers are on
the board all of those type of things
right you know at pick 18 they're airing
a spot too where
would the other picks they have they
could trade up a few picks trade back a
few picks they're just so much
flexibility so i kind of find the
dolphins the most intriguing one
i'm stunned i'm stunned all the time
we've spent talking about with the 49ers
i already know what's going on there be
there okay
but i want to see i want to see the
reactions the body language the subtle
eye rolls i'd be constantly scanning the
radar is just oscillating like a fan
checking out everybody how are they
reacting to that third overall pick and
then what else are they gonna do to try
to make that team better but because of
that third overall pick for the
precursor the build up as they keep it
all very secret you know what what can i
glean and and then again after it's done
how are they acting how are they
reacting plus i mean you know certain
things are legal in california i'm
surprised you wouldn't want to be out
there oh you're right i mean sign me up
let me go come on here we go um
yeah i i listen i thought about them i
did
we've talked about it so much
and you would want to be there though
you're right to see the reactions of
everybody see the what the reactions of
the the scouts of the guy you know the
guys who you know don't agree with the
pick and all that that would be very
funny and i've gotten to see that a
little in new england which was uh
interesting to see too all right the
next one for me
i i think i'd want to go to jacksonville
yeah it's the number one pick i get that
but again it's all the other picks too
that added to the fact of i'd kind of
want to see urban meyer in his first
draft and what you know the whole
the whole situation is like for him how
he handles it what's his dialogue like
with trent balke all of that you know
how they interact with shot khan it's
going to be interesting i think this has
been a bit of a culture shock for urban
meyer not that he hasn't handled it you
know really well but like he said i mean
he he said free agency was different he
wished things were could be tweaked that
way i i'd be intrigued to see one of the
greatest college coaches of all time in
his first nfl draft very underrated
storyline too the fact that trent baucke
and jim harbaugh the michigan coach that
urban meyer beat every time he played
him hated each other never talked about
that despised each other and now balcony
is open meyer's right hand that's great
see how long they go until uh hey by the
way tell your dad i said hi all right
next one for me
screw you new england new england new
england patriots i gotta be there but
when are they ever going to have 15 when
if they had 15 when are they going to
have 15 again are they going to try to
trade up who and what's matt patricia
doing now he's like doing all these
different jobs he doesn't have a title
he's doing all this stuff he's
negotiating contracts he's making phone
calls who's really there as the
right-hand man for bill belichick i
think if you're in that draft room
you're going to see that matt patricia
is a lot closer to the nick casario role
than maybe anyone else's currently in
that building would be with all that
talk about the things patricia's doing
not really a coach more of a gm and
peter king said when the rams
interviewed patricia to be the head
coach they came away from it thinking
that guy would be a hell of a gm in the
nfl yeah yeah it's uh you know
i i hear you there i mean it's it's the
patriots you'd always like to be in
their room i mean i worked there and i
still wanted to be in the damn room i
was on the outside of the room having no
clue but i mean anytime
bill belichick is talking about football
i want to hear because there's going to
be deep-rooted smart logic in that
conversation and you're right it's
always interesting to see kind of the
pecking order you don't know how things
work in new england nobody really does i
mean nobody the people that work there
don't really know how it works i think
that's part of the reason a lot of them
don't succeed when they leave sometimes
because they're like i don't really know
what went on to make those decisions i
was always on the other room doing what
i had to do so uh i think there's
something to that i would love to be
there one thing one thing yeah i think
one thing i would love to have seen
nine years ago right the year that you
were there for the draft right when bill
belichick and burge nigerian are meeting
and burge has the list of all the people
who may or may not be invited into the
draft room and they say sims the belt
god no
you know the the other belt just a
classic hug let me just roll his eyes
and shake his head that was so not
possible of happening that never even
got to that conversation they knew i was
already they weren't even on the list i
wasn't you weren't even on the list that
list in there is a short list let me
just tell you
it's like four people in the craft
family that is all that's in there and
everybody else is just a spectator so
i'm surprised the crafts get in yeah
they do they get in yep they got the
money to do it so they're allowed to um
i'm gonna go with the ravens as my last
pick you know i know the jets got a lot
of picks and are interesting howie rosen
and the eagles are interesting too but i
think with the ravens making this big
trade you know and just how they
orchestrate the end of the draft i think
would be interesting to be involved in
that you know i have such great respect
for their ability to scout players and
build a team and do all of that it's a
weird year in the draft there's not a
lot of high-end talent that'll be there
to be available at the end of the first
round i i would love to just see kind of
their thoughts what's eric decosta and
john harbaugh talking about you know and
of course they are they're a trade down
possibility too so i'd i'd be all in
favor of having a front row seat to that
i'll say cowboys first preliminarily if
it's a yacht but assuming it's not on
the yacht yes i'll go i'll go with the
panthers
uh i'm i'm just intrigued by this
dynamic between matt rule scott federer
david tepper
you know and they're going to be maybe
calling up to trade north or getting
calls to trade down and how do they how
do they parse all that out and and you
know the chaos theory we talked about
earlier if mac jones ends up not being
the pick at number three yeah and starts
to slide right to sam darnold suddenly
become a very short-term option in
carolina yeah i would think so and then
really i mean yeah
you would think that
if the quarterback thing didn't happen
that they could be a really big trade
down target so uh that would be a fun
one to be involved in
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports